4000 personas esperaban tomar un tren
entraba torso cuando un misil de corto
alcance alcanzó al lugar dejando decenas
de fallecidos el presidente de ucrania
volodymyr selenski relacionó el ataque
con el dibuja y pidió ayuda
entre los principales estados del mundo
ya han condenado el ataque de rusia en
cama torso esperamos una respuesta firme
e internacional a este crimen de guerra
al igual que la masacre de muchas y
otros crímenes de guerra rusos el ataque
con misiles en cama torch debe ser
confirmado por el tribunal aunque no
está seguro de que llegó no hay aquí o
podios como minutos mientras tanto rusia
volvió a utilizar la misma respuesta de
lucha y negoció implicación en el ataque
otras fuerzas armadas de ucrania
atacaron la estación de tren de cromatos
con un mes y táctico dos con dos misiles
tácticos scouts cuyos fragmentos
encontraron cerca de la estación de
crematorio son utilizados únicamente por
las fuerzas armadas de ucrania
una respuesta que no parece convencer a
la comunidad internacional desde eeuu la
casa blanca fue contundente a la hora de
calificar la actuación de rusia power
sim lo que hemos visto en el transcurso
de las últimas seis semanas ha sido lo
que el propio presidente ha
caracterizado como crímenes de guerra es
decir atacar intencionalmente a civiles
a observación desde la otan advierten
que la guerra podría durar años mientras
que moscú asegura que se trata de una
operación especial para desmilitarizar y
desclasificar ucrania y esperan tomar el
control del este y el sur de ucrania lo
que consideran parte de la nueva rusia